one thing i'll just say you know because
a lot of people who are entrepreneurs
come in they think they can just kind of
kind of waltz in and and the political
system and it doesn't work that way you
really have to become part of the
ecosystem
[Music]
josh becker thank you for joining in 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm very good thank you for having me
thank you for taking the time to do this
i know you just got back from a long
trip so i really appreciate
it and i know how busy you are brief
background and then i'm going to ask so
many questions because
i know so little about the things that
you do and you know the
the scope of the things that you do but
they're so fascinating so
a stanford business school but also a
law degree from stanford always
thinking about you know public interest
entrepreneurship
what does that even mean i can sense by
the name but i don't really know
the full circle fund helping non-profits
i think you've deployed over
100 000 hours of help through that
incredible and you're running for state
senate
uh this year which i also i'm excited to
learn about what that
transformation is like and what it means
to innovate within government
okay let's take a break now josh tell me
who you are please
well thanks yeah this is really fun i
really appreciate you having me
um yeah and thinking about it i mean
there are themes that that run through
all that and for me it really
is innovation i love innovation in
any respect so whether in the private
sector in the non-private sector
or now in the government sector and you
know for me that's really been a theme
i actually started out more on a public
policy basis i mean out of
undergrad i was really focused on
environment
environmental activism went to dc worked
in policy
worked in some campaigns and it was
almost a fluke really that i ended up
in business school but in the in between
time i applied and i came
out i got involved with a guy named jack
hillary starting an early internet
company called earthweb
and there's 1994 early days of the web
uh you know bringing a physical computer
over to the metropolitan museum of art
showing them in the web saying hey we'll
build a website for you
and i got really involved by the time i
i came out to stanford
you know in 1995 i was like wow this is
really
a great place to be and so i got really
into
innovation in the private sector in the
early internet days and ultimately
in in cleantech um
and i became to see a way to really meld
my common interest
in the public good with um
in innovation and i did it both in we
call
impact investing and this was the really
early days we started to fund
uh in the impact investing space which
actually is now growing
and we're focusing on on businesses that
had a real social impact so clean energy
was one of them
wow but that's that's pretty you know i
i go to quite a few of the classes at
the business school and i and a lot of
my friends are
the stanford business school it's pretty
rare that somebody
comes in there and goes out of there
with the sense of responsibility of
you know devoting most of their time to
doing social good a lot i mean right
there is a trend a lot of people are
saying yes i want my business to do
social good but you're saying
it's it's it's about the social good
it's not about necessarily just the
business
the social good is the motivation it's
not just a bi
it's not it's not just you know it comes
by consequence right
yeah and i see me i mean personally i
see a lot of young students right now
that you are really
interested in as you say in that
intersection but yeah we were kind of on
the early edge of that
um and in fact we had our own conference
we were created called the zero
trade-off investment conference
we're looking at things that can
actually create a great financial return
and a great
social return right um but clean energy
was was one of those and we
you know got involved a company called
oh power that was really about
using um social psychology to get people
to reduce their energy use
and that has been you know huge success
and you know again show me what's
possible inner city we've had a focus on
inner city and ethnic entrepreneurs
so um still on the board of a uh company
that's not good you are welcome you are
uh
welcome with you and i are and um
it's kind of like a usaa for immigrants
um
and then we had an inner city uh
something called the villa which was an
inner city
shoe store really a guy who took his
parents sneaker store and started
opening up the inner city and building
wow
life's you know work skills and life
skills and
um into a number of those things then
full circle fund i realized so many of
my friends
from business school and law school that
did have a really deep interest in
doing good in the world but they were
busy everyone's you know you're busy
with your lives your work your kids
and so we said let's pull together our
time and our money and that was full
circle fun we started that actually this
is
almost exactly 20 years ago this is our
20th anniversary year
wow and um and just that way i found you
know
like you see some books behind me i find
when i'm part of a book club i read more
books so when i'm part of something like
full circle
um i end up giving more because you
build a social
community around giving and it's also
it's available so i mean right now
right a lot of the a lot of this idea of
you want to get something done you
you know i i love behavioral economics
when you talk about the social
psychology of
of reducing energy so and it's it's you
know dana reality is a big mentor of
mine and one of the things that i was
always inspired by him was he says
listen we're irrational people we can't
really it's very hard to change
ourselves but if we can change our
environment
to fit what we want to achieve like
joining a book club and then you're
systematically forced to read a book
or if you want or or you're joining the
full circle fund and now you have the
accessibility to go and help others
i think that i think that's marvelous
josh tell me a little bit about this
you know innovation and government
because i want to make sure we leave
enough time for this because i think
it's
fascinating you're running for senate
what what how do you do this
transition from entrepreneur investor to
government what motivates you to do that
sure i probably have danielle's book
right behind wonderful the um
yeah you know i think you know you kind
of look and see where you can have the
biggest impact and when i started
uh really focusing on the state of
california realizing you know we have a
200 billion dollar budget
you know as if it were our own country
would be the fifth or sixth largest
economy in the world
and there's really not that many state
senators just 40 state senators
and um and probably you know five to 10
of those 40 who are really
um probably the most influential and
then saul began to see that as an
opportunity for change essentially this
is the board of directors for the state
of california the the united states
senate and the state house
and when i sort of focus on that i just
said oh well this is a real
uh opportunity and you listen i'm sure
um and i talked for friends up there now
and
you know it is still you know you're 40
in the senate 80 in this
in the house so still 120 people still
um
you know i'm sure it's gonna be
bureaucratic at times and but when you
look at the opportunity for leverage
i think it's tremendous and whether it's
meeting our clean energy goals
we're california i think it's the hope
certainly for the us and and
one of the big hopes for the world and
oh i'm really excited about
collaboration as i've done in my past
life um about collaborating with israel
and the amazing technology around water
uh totally up and around solar around
storage
uh that's coming out of israel really
looking forward to collaborating there
so in you know whether it was clean
energy whether it was um focusing on
social justice and criminal justice
reform
that the california was this huge
leverage point
and i got really excited about that and
and that's what
you know that's what i'm going up there
to do that's incredible so and is this
like a you know a spontaneous
you know gut feeling that you have to do
this or is this something that you feel
like you've worked towards
for years which of these two you know
it's a little bit of both to be honest i
mean like i said i started out in dc you
know before i came out to stanford and
business school law school you know i
was already focused on policy so
it's not you know like a brand new like
i woke up one day and decided i had to
do it
so i'd say it was more of an evolution
um in terms of really
like i never thought i would personally
run um that's something i never thought
for sure
would ever happen so but i was always
very interested in policy
you may be more so than other kids or
other you know young adults so i'd say
it's a bit of an evolution
right and i mean you're gonna come there
i don't know how many
uh people that are senators have a
background
this entrepreneurial and innovative
background that you have
do you think that's gonna be a challenge
or or is that going to be you know a fun
experience
being the sort of the odd one now you
know i think it'll
i think it'll be a little bit of uh uh i
think a little bit of both
i'm sure it'll be some um you know
eye-opening situations
um i'm sure maybe a little bit of both
uh but i'm i am really excited about it
and hopefully people will turn to me on
certain issues and look at me
that i've got some degree of of
expertise
uh to bring right at the same time you
know i need to be humble as well and
realize
there's a lot i have to learn about the
state of california i'm already starting
now but you know it's such a massive
state with
whether it's the agricultural economy
the hollywood economy the tech economy
there's just so much to um to learn like
i said i just got back on this trip
you know all the way down the eastern
sierras all the way to death valley it's
a really incredibly diverse state so
i've got a lot to learn i think it's
unbelievable but you know
the perception of young entrepreneurs
like myself when we think of you know
government
senator congressman we we look back at
these these funny videos with zuckerberg
sitting in front of congress and they're
asking him well how do so
how do ads work are you you know
tracking people and are you
showing them stuff that they should buy
and and you know so
in our perception somebody who sits in
the government is not necessarily the
most tech savvy and not necessarily the
best representative
of where of where innovation takes it
you're bringing a different perspective
to this
do you so are you how do you see sort of
this
this mishmash of you know both
bureaucracy
and innovation and tech and you know
crises that are happening i mean you
really have to balance everything
yeah i think when you look great change
in government and i've also done that
law by the way i started a whole company
spent 10 years in legal analytics we
brought data and analytics to the law
which was a law so what does that mean
bringing data and analytics to the law
yeah in politics sometimes you got to
play the long game uh too and
um you know thinking driving across the
state you know i've been on the board of
uc merced for 15 years
that was the government decision said
hey we need to start a new uc campus
in the central valley and you know first
it was
you know 100 students and now it would
be 10 000 students
and we just had my friend jack's now a
google access we had a great call now
that
you know google is getting serious about
diversifying the stem pipeline and
we've got all these great diverse you
know engineering students coming in
wonderful
and so you know some of you guys but you
know it took a long you know it didn't
happen overnight but
it was you know people were very forward
thinking to say hey great we need a new
uc let's put it in the central valley
let's
um encourage you know college attendance
and and um so as soon as you got to play
the long game in government
no no and jack is actually a very good
friend of my father's and i
he's every time i meet him i'm my mind
is just blown
uh it's the work they're doing they're
on on quantum computing is just
phenomenal
but so bringing analytics and data to
legal what does that mean what what did
you try to do there
sure you know basically in a nutshell we
realized um it's not really around
patent
uh some you know area that a lot of
entrepreneurs
uh get very frustrated with our system
and we realize there's just
there's no data there's no data about
when you get hit with a patent lawsuit
who is this person assuming what's their
pattern behavior
are they looking for a quick buck or
this is a serious company that writes
things all the way and
and you know and they've got a serious
claim here there's really there's no
data no data about judges
who's this judgement front of what is
their pattern what is her pattern of
behavior
um and so we realize it's endemic in law
there's just no data and so we said
that data is actually out there it's
just buried in millions of lawsuits
so we said hey we can you know extract
out these millions of data points from
millions of cases
then we can tell you if you're in front
of a certain judge we can say hey
in the last thousand cases of this type
in front of this judge
um here's the lawyers that have the most
experience who won the most
motions here's you know a strategy you
might think about pursuing
and um and you know here's how this
judge is ruled in these kinds
i mean i think i kind of blindly assume
that this is how a lot of these law
firms work today that when they're
advising on a case they're able to look
back at thousands of other similar cases
because you know history repeats itself
constantly and and be able to give those
insights so you're saying that that's
not really the case
well i know a lot of brilliant lawyers
but you can't keep
three thousand cases in your head i mean
it's been the ultimate anecdata
business right it's like oh yeah i had
this case in front of this
just and i remember this and you know um
and really i love that anik data i've
never heard that before i'm gonna
i'm gonna start using that anecdotes
data and
that's really what it's been it's all
reputation based too oh this law firm's
got a great reputation of you you know i
did a great lawyer
you gotta talk to you know lisa um but
really there's just no data behind it
i mean it's like vc2 frankly you know
you always put your wins you know if you
go to any vc website it's
going to say oh look at all our great
exits they don't say
you know oh here's the other 100
companies we invested in that didn't
make it right 100 just
you know i mean now you know with crunch
bit i mean now people have got a little
more data there but
that was also a data void interesting so
you start and so when was is that you
started
this firm so this is actually it was a
public interest project
at stanford law um and what was amazing
you probably know andrew ing
of course google day so andrew when he
was uh
still full-time at stanford and then
chris manning who runs natural language
processing
yeah the uh the
founders of this public interest project
went to andrew and chris and said would
you help us and they first said no
because they're very busy and then
ultimately they said hey this is good
for the country and they got involved
and they got excited about and
chris you know of national language
processing so this was i was very
fortunate this is way before i was
involved this was back in 2006 2007
and then it spun off as it was a public
interest project
in late 2010 they brought me in 2011 to
grow it
so but it took you know it still took
nine years now it's part of lexisnexis
and it's growing you know
we just passed three million cases that
are now in the system we just added
a whole new area of law we're starting
to add states now because so much what
happens at the state level and that's
even
much much harder of course to even get
the raw materials
because most states don't even have
electronic court records
you know it's been the long game the
long journey but it's now trans
it's really transforming the way law is
practical wow so you worked on projects
with the jack hillary
that you're this project was had
involved with andering and chris and
i mean these are just you know the top
of the top of the top of the world
thinkers so i think that's just that's
incredible what are you most excited
about moving forward
and and actually right before that the
election
how does it even work like what like
what do you have to do
because it you know a lot of the times
when you know people in tech they're
thinking of the you know politicians and
and
you know the elections it almost it
seems like oh yeah he has to go do that
he has to go and say
and and talk these he has to go talk he
can't just do
talk to me a little bit about this
election process sure one thing i'll
just say you know because a lot of
people
who are entrepreneurs come in they think
they can just kind of kind of waltz in
and and the political system and it
doesn't work that way you
really have to become part of the
ecosystem you know you have to really
get to know
um all the players and you know what
y'all you say what 98 of life is just
showing up
you really have to show up at all the
local democratic clubs and all the local
uh meetings and really get to know
people you can't just walk in and say
hey i'm gonna run for this this thing
you're it's just it's it's a very
different um the world's even here in
silicon valley are just not connected
people
you know in fact it can also be a
negative in some way so
you really so i really put in many years
of hard work
um and fun work but you know hard work
at the local level and
just you know getting to know people and
and and spent 18 months before the
primary even
in this race alone so um
you know because we have 24 cities in my
district and it spans all silicon valley
from south san francisco down to
sunnyvale
and you know each one of city council
members each has school board members
there's county officials and
they're doing hard work for many years
and you've got to understand that so
you really have to put in the time and
i'm i'm proud that i did that finished
first in the primary we have in
california a great system
a top two system so basically that's why
two vote getters
advance and what that means is usually
you actually have two democrats in this
area so people then get to choose
between a flavor of democrat
right or in orange county might have two
republicans
actually in my race um i did very well
and
there was a lot of other democrats so it
ended up being me and a republican that
will be facing off in um in november so
we have the time for the whole for the
whole state
um what do you say that that's going to
be for the whole state
no again no no this is this is our
district so we have uh
each state sanitizer's about a million
people so our district is from
everything from basically everything
from the border of san francisco
down to sunnyvale okay so i get the uh
israeli kibbutz and sunnyvale as part of
mine
as part of my uh 100 you know i thought
it was i had a talk with
with the mayor of sunnyvale back then uh
larry about back in you know
what was it i think two three months ago
and i thought and then
halfway through the talk he mentioned
that he's also a program manager at a
startup
at a battery startup and i thought it
was just it was it was hilarious that he
that you know i'm talking to a mayor of
a city you know in israel
you never have that so i think it was
just it was just phenomenal
and what are you most excited about you
know the next few years and potentially
you know serving as a senator
yeah very excited about the opportunity
to make change in areas that we've we've
talked about
yeah clean energy got to lead the world
uh criminal justice reform um
education you know talk higher education
i mean we need three more uc merceds uh
in this state um more access for kids
those are just a few of the areas but
i'm really excited about the opportunity
um you know to to lead in all those
build the world-class
transportation system here especially in
the bay area i just got off a call on
that
so those are some things i'm really
passionate about and now looking at this
you know this crisis that we're facing
globally and you're the intersection of
both innovation and government so you're
getting the flavor of both
you know in your take what where are we
headed with this
and what are you know the things to be
either optimistic about
or pessimistic about well i think
there's room to be optimistic and we've
seen
even through this pandemic um both how
communities have rallied i mean
certainly in the u.s we have some
divisiveness and polarization
right now that we need to get through um
but you've also seen there's a lot of
great stories about neighbors helping
neighbors and
and innovation whether people how
they're running their small businesses
differently
how cities are opening up streets for
restaurants
um or how i just got emailed today i've
looked at a guy hey i'm leaving samsung
to leave this copic related
company and it's like wow really cool so
i mean there's
a lot of people doing really cool um
work and it's gonna
and and biotech is also an area spent a
lot of time on now
um especially in oncology and and
you know to see the we will have a
vaccine and faster than we've ever had
one before and
um you know it's not overnight as these
as these things are
but we're getting there and the
innovation piece is critical
100 josh thank you so much for your time
i really appreciate it
and thank you for doing this right after
you after you're back from your trip
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words that best describe you
thank you um i would say
innovative um thoughtful
and passionate innovative thoughtful
passion and i think you know one of the
things that i'm most
is inspired by and i'm taking a lesson
for myself is this uh
persistence and consistency with putting
the public interest first i think it
shines on all the different endeavors
over the over the past decades
and the fact that you're able to do
these endeavors with you know the the
greatest
thought leaders in the world uh
seriously i mean all
all the people that we've talked about i
mean they're really just incredible and
i'm very very excited and that you know
people are now entering
the the politics based on government
with the
insight and the experience of what it
takes to bring innovation
and and thank you very much i look
forward to seeing you up there
thank you thanks for having me take care
bye